I got on the phone with Sam after I
watched the pilot he was like yeah I
want to do a musical number and it'll be
beautiful and it'll be heartbreaking I
was you know listening to this
flabyrinth track you know all for us and
there was something that was so big and
triumphant and beautiful Sam gotta
energy from it and was like this really
feels like group then when he told me
wanted to use it for music was like okay
that's a visionary and when he told me
that I would be able to record it I was
like are you joking she listened to my
version taking it off or she was like
I'm not gonna do that but I'm gonna do
my version you know that's the perfect
way of approaching music came up with
the idea to add a marching band and an
even bigger choir because we wanted to
make sure it was very massive percussion
came in and they did their parts
[Music]
and then we had the woodwinds and the
brass
[Music]
I'm watching this India and I was
watching her watch the ban and I could
only look at her reactions that's why
she must like that it's pretty cool the
choir totally got into it they were
connecting with the song and they were
having fun it just got bigger and bigger
and bigger Ryan Heffington was our
choreographer my job mr. Rangel two
hundred people it's not always just
choreographing but it's also infusing
the scene with an importance when I saw
it out in the streets I got that sort of
pit my stomach of oh we got to do this
justice Sam of course came up with the
most elaborate scenario he could to have
this spectacular ending it was kind of
conceived as a bit of this Death March
it becomes sort of an extension of what
she's feeling the joy the release the
freedom that drugs bring and at the same
time the real kind of horror
sometimes there's moments where you're
editing a scene where you have this
feeling of like oh wow this is going to
be genuinely truly special whilst
shooting everybody had such a good
energy it was so happy and excited to be
there it felt very magical I think we've
all kind of went home saying
you
you